it is May 4th 2023 and you are watching
the code report python is a wonderful
language for productive programming but
it has one big problem it's too slow and
going slow means you'll get made fun of
by the rust and C plus Chads of the
world but the tables are about to turn
thanks to a brand new programming
language called Mojo a superset of
python that's not just two times faster
not ten times faster but up to 35 000
times faster than your grandpa's Python
and that's a huge deal because Python's
the dominant language for artificial
intelligence but behind the curtain
anything that needs to go fast is
written in C or C plus plus in today's
video we'll take Mojo for a spin but
first here are five things that you need
to know about it one this is not some
random guy's side project on GitHub but
rather it comes from a company founded
by Chris lattner the guy who created the
Swift programming language and the llvm
compiler tool chain if anybody could fix
Python's problems it's him and if you
have no idea what llvm is check out this
video two it's a language designed for
programming on AI Hardware like gpus
running Cuda and other accelerators it
achieves this by Leverage multi-level
intermediate representation to scale to
Exotic Hardware types without a ton of
complexity and it even has built-in Auto
tuning to optimize your code for your
Target Hardware three it's designed as a
super set of python in the same way
typescript is a superset of JavaScript
so you don't need to learn another
language to take advantage of it and
this is unique compared to other modern
systems languages like rust Zig Nim and
so on which would have a higher learning
curve for existing python programmers it
does have a bunch of features on top of
python like VAR and Lut declarations and
structs but the base language is fully
compatible with python and it can also
interop with the python ecosystem which
means you can still use your favorite
libraries like numpy pandas Etc or it
adds strong type checking to the
language you can still use Dynamic types
if you prefer but static types are
essential for optimized performance and
error checking for memory management it
has an ownership system and borrow
Checkers similar to rust and also
supports manual memory management with
pointers like C plus plus it's a
pragmatic language that gives you safety
but also the flexibility to be unsafe
when needed now the final thing to know
is that currently it's not available to
the public it's still in very early
development it will be open sourced in
the future but currently there is a wait
list to try it out I was lucky enough to
get Early Access so let's fire it up to
run it you can create a file ending in
dot Mojo or dot fire Emoji that's a huge
advantage over python which doesn't
allow you to name your files in dot
snake but we can also run the code in a
Jupiter notebook where it behaves like
an interpreted language here we have a
matrix multiplication demo that computes
a DOT product to demonstrate the crazy
performance gains we get with Mojo first
it benchmarks a basic function in Python
then by simply importing that code into
Mojo it's executed 14 times faster with
no modifications to the code but we're
only just getting started we can further
optimize this code by adding types to
the python implementation Mojo allows us
to do that with its built-in struct
keyword a struct is very similar to a
python class but structs are static
unlike classes which are Dynamic inside
this truck we ALS have keywords like VAR
and let which can Define mutable and
immutable variables and Def is replaced
with FN which is a stricter type type of
function also notice single instruction
multiple data which is a built-in type
that represents a vector where a single
instruction can be executed across
multiple elements in parallel on the
underlying Hardware once we have this
struct we can then use it as a type in
the python implementation then when we
Benchmark the code again we get a
ridiculous 500x performance boost but
we're still not happy yet in the Inner
Loop we can query the vector width
instead of hard coding it and that gives
us a thousand X gain but that's nothing
compared to what we're about to do
linear algebra is perfect for parallel
Computing and we can easily make our
code multi-threaded with the built-in
parallelized function increasing our
speed buff to 2000x but now I've got a
fever and the only prescription is more
performance luckily Mojo has built-in
tiling utilities that basically allow us
to cache and reuse data more efficiently
and we can even auto-tune it to find the
optimal parameters for our Hardware the
end result is over four thousand times
faster execution compared to the
original python code that's pretty crazy
and if you want to see this code broken
down in Greater detail I'd highly
recommend this video from Jeremy Howard
but I'm curious is what you guys think
do you really think Mojo could kill
Python and C plus at the same time I'm a
bit skeptical but employers are already
hiring Mojo developers with 10 years of
experience this has been the code report
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one
[Music]